we've got this from timcast.com Trump
roasts DeSantis 2024 presidential
campaign announcement quote wow the Des
Sanctus Twitter launch is a disaster
Trump said and uh we've got a bunch of
memes that all of these Trump supporters
are posting team Trump posted this is
probably one of the this may be one of
the worst ones Ron with the exclamation
point like Jeb and uh what is what is
this falling over is that is that a
rocket falling over is that what is that
supposed to be it's a failure to launch
it's supposed to be a rocket that shoots
up
from uh when Elon elon's rocket didn't
like take off probably that's what I
thought it looked like one of them yeah
yeah
so this morning I was talking about this
too because you know the announcement
comes yesterday at 6 p.m we've now had a
full 24 hours plus of media reactions
the media is going nuts I don't really
care like I don't like their opinion to
begin with but you've got the left and
the right basically pointing it to
Santa's being like yo that was really
really bad and there are these DeSantis
I don't know I don't know is there
what's a word for someone who's like a
die hard for DeSantis whatever
no I'm inventing it it's a distantis a
distantis yeah there's stance
yes well they they are and they're on
Twitter and they're they're posting this
stuff and it's just like look man
that that Ron with the exclamation point
really does sum it up a lot and you were
saying this before the show yeah that he
could Jeb out yes and that's actually my
call I think he's getting ready to flame
out like we just saw yesterday he's
doing he's gonna jab out yeah you know
real quick and this is this is something
that's kind of near and dear to my heart
that's really important to me and that's
and that's loyalty so president Trump
has endorsed me the last two cycles and
so when he came out and announced back
in November I was literally it he
finished like the last syllable we
endorse him immediately because it's
really important to me he helped get me
here Ron DeSantis would not be the
governor of Florida if not for Donald
Trump and so what I'm seeing here is a
level of disloyalty I think he's going
to pay for ultimately and that's just
not how you treat someone that got you
this far he's 44 years old he's the
governor of the Free State of Florida
and by the way from what I could tell
he's done a pretty good job at it yeah
just be loyal to the person that got you
here in the first place and then you
could be The Heir Apparent for the
future but my fear is that he is being
talked into doing this by a lot of other
people that are going to make a lot of
money and basically what we saw
yesterday we were kind of talking about
it before the show how he looks like a
hostage patient right now he looks like
he's being held hostage to do this and I
think there are a lot of people in
Florida that simply want him to stay in
Florida and be the governor and do the
job that they elected him to do yeah
this is something that brought up was
brought up as we're setting everything
up well he's not going to win Florida
for two for two reasons people love
Trump and a lot of people in Florida who
vote for Santa's probably would choose
to vote for Trump but also the people
who really love DeSantis are going to be
like not to keep him here that's exactly
right you said this before the show
they're gonna have their cake and eat it
too they're going to get Trump as the
president and to Santa says their
governor who would who would I would
love to have that and you brought that
point up and I've never I've actually
never heard that before that's
absolutely spot on because I always look
at it from like a head-to-head
standpoint but if I were literally a
citizen that was living in the Free
State of Florida and based on the last
few years being in basically Florida and
Texas where I'm from I call those the
last two free states of our Union and
and the idea of the job that he has done
as Governor you mean to tell me that I
get to have President Trump on top of
this ticket and I get to keep DeSantis
as my Governor why in God's they would I
not want that I have I have never heard
that point it's a very Salient Point too
as well because it's very simple I know
you should choose that but we've had
tons of people comment on this show
people have called in saying we don't
want our governor to leave yes yeah so
like sorry look it's he's going to get
termed out but he's got some time left
plenty of time
left no one here is saying oh de Santa
says some horrible swap monster we hate
him we hope Trump destroys him it's the
opposite I want desensis to be
successful I don't think the best
possible move for him right now is to
leave Florida I could totally be wrong
about that I'm not making predictions
here but what I am saying is this
genuinely comes from a place of saying
all right there are so few good
political leaders in America today that
when there is one doing a really good
job in Florida and he's got a long
career ahead of him maybe it's not the
right time for him to run for president
he would also be I think what the second
youngest president or would it make him
the youngest that 44 second after after
JFK how old is Jack okay
oh look was he 42 no I'll look no you
won't let's get there
how old was JFK when he elected my
confused my computer froze so Hannah
might actually beat me that's not my
name uh
anyways uh 43-11 oh wow 43 I'd be the
second youngest president oh my computer
he's got time but you know uh I was
talking about this this morning dude if
if you're gonna sit here and lie to
defend DeSantis over his lack of
Charisma you'll lose and if you're gonna
come out and try and try and defend that
he has no Charisma with but his policies
are great that reminds me of that
Futurama bit where the Amazonian women
introduce the men to their WNBA and
they're like no Ken dunk but good
fundamentals it's like okay dude the the
the being the loud strong voice is
dunking you can be you can be in all
let's just let's just acquit the
basketball there are tons of really
really great basketball football players
yeah you'll never remember their names
they're really well-rounded they they
they have really great stats and then
there's those those star players that
you just know are commanding the massive
salaries this is also so an important
point for people to consider it's
something that is really lost on people
and this is some it's a mistake I made
by the way when uh I was looking at the
2016 election there were politicians
whose policies I liked more than Trump
and so I was saying those people should
have gotten the nomination at the time
now obviously Trump grew on me over the
years and I really like him now
but at the time my thoughts were well
this political leader has better
policies but the reality as a politician
is not just a set of policies they're a
presence they're a person they're a
leader they have to be capable of doing
certain things and one of the things
that whoever gets selected by the
Republicans to be the nominee has to be
able to do
is be charismatic enough to win a
general election now many people have
responded to this by arguing that Joe
Biden isn't charismatic okay Joe Biden
doesn't have good policies either what
Joe Biden had was a massive leg up he
had massive institutional support that
no Republican nominee is going to get so
saying Biden one of the worst candidates
of all time won so we don't have to be
very selective about the level of
Charisma our candidates have is not an
argument because guess what whoever ends
up winning in 2024 if it's a republican
Time Magazine isn't going to come out
several months from now with an article
about how every major institution in the
country coalesced to get him elected
when the Democrat nominee is chosen be
it Biden Time Magazine is going to show
a smiling Biden with a light blue
background shaking hands and no matter
which Republican it is they're going to
superimpose their face on Hitler's
bodies
everywhere exactly I think Charisma does
make a difference I mean I said this
before the show but uh every politician
I'm sure you can speak to this surround
themselves with people who are able to
come up with strong policy it's part of
having a strong staff so
they're not always the person who has a
the front of the room they're not always
the person making speeches Chris makes a
huge difference uh Ron DeSantis team
just released that they fundraise 8.4
million dollars since his announcement
since his official launch yesterday in
uh 2019 Trump raised 24.8 million
dollars in the 24 hours after he
launched his re-election campaign there
is such a a serious
um weight to Charisma to leadership to
Persona and the numbers alone tell us
that DeSantis is not it I mean again I
think he's talented I'm happy for him to
have a long career I think we should
have a strong deep uh bench of
politicians who are really willing to
lead the country in the right direction
but you cannot deny that Donald Trump
has something wrong to San Francisco
real quick the fundraising for Trump
numbers was that you said 20 2019 2019.
he announces re-election campaign 24.8
million dollars unless can we look up uh
2015 yeah to see what he raised I'd be
curious because you had a really wide
field then I think at what 17 candidates
or whatever now you've got three or four
so that I've actually announced yeah
right right so I'd be interested to see
it's hard to do a one for you can't
really do a one-for-one comparison
because the total different numbers I'd
be willing to bet the reason I asked
though is that in 2015 Trump probably
raised a lot of money relative to what
you know to the field but then again I
mean everyone thought Cruz was going to
win very early on right it bounced
around a lot of people are pointing out
that uh at this time in Trump's uh first
campaign his polling was way way way
down yeah so we will see but guys look I
pulled up Barack Obama's announcement
from 2000 I think 2007. it was it was it
was fire it was it was passion he's got
this massive crowd of people he does
this slow build up and that's why
ah Barack Obama I'm announcing my
candidacy and Rising the raising the
voice everyone ah yeah Rhonda Sanders
went well I'm running for president to
uh lead the Great American comeback and
uh I'm like okay well this is another
important thing to consider which is
that presidential campaign spending has
been one of the number one predictors of
who gets elected for decades and Trump
actually broke that mold the kit the
Clinton campaign outspent Trump about
two to one and Jeb two by the way yeah
oh interesting in the primaries way more
than he's initially absolutely that
makes perfect sense to me though right
because no matter how much money people
throw at you even if you know I
shouldn't say no matter how much money
people throw at you because we know that
if you do have massive Capital behind
you in all of corporate America's got
your back yeah you're gonna have a
higher chance of success no doubt but
the fact that Trump was able to overcome
those odds is really really incredible I
mean and I would just encourage everyone
to to uh just quickly look up the charts
of campaign spending since the 1960s
you'll find that basically every single
election the person who outspent one
with the exception of trump vs Clinton
I I want to say I want to say I want to
tell you a quick story about about
Charisma and what Charisma really means
so a couple of months ago president
Trump came down to Waco Texas and did a
rally and I got to speak at the rally
and when Trump showed up to the rally it
was at an Airfield
so there were thousands of people
waiting in line four or five hours in a
day to go to this rally and do you know
how president Trump showed up
in his plane he does a low pass over the
crowd and then you know the music he
starts playing at the rally danger zone
and then taxis around behind the stage
where there is a red carpet waiting
where he gets off the plane walks on the
red carpet onto the stage you know and
it's like I'm here yeah that's the
difference between what we saw yesterday
and what you will see at a trump rally
it's like comparing apples to orangutans
it's not even close there there is a
video that Trump put out that shows a
flyover with jets
a pack for DeSantis
superimposed jets with fake jet noises
flying over to santis it's not helping
guys like I know that it wasn't the
DeSantis campaign that did that someone
did and I'm just like Trump's got the
real flyover he was President like you
got to know where you can and can't win
in in the pr space but that's correct no
question I've seen that the plane
pulling up I think I was in Leesburg I
can't remember the the the jumbo jet
pulling in slowly Trump walks right
everyone walks right up to the stage and
there he is afterwards he walks down to
the barricades that's shaking hands with
everybody yes he is he is an 80s man and
he is he is a charismatic leader well I
just want to throw this out there again
you can be a massive DeSantis fan and
still refuse to pretend that the emperor
is wearing clothes when he isn't there's
a lot of things to like about DeSantis
it's okay to say that he can work on
solving the problem of his lack of
Charisma we we were mentioned this a
moment ago if they did not give him
proper media training then he's in
trouble he's done if they did and that
was the best they could do
he's done he's done so also I will say
this too Rhonda Sanders peaked in
November
after the election in November after the
midterm election where we didn't perform
as well that's exactly where the Santa's
Peak and he ended up winning Florida by
how much like 20 23 points and even one
in Miami won by this huge margin yeah
yeah and even back in November he was
still behind the president and if you
look at the polling if you look at uh
the attraction ever since it's just been
a precipitous fall off November and he's
not getting better thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time